Mình và thần chuyến sau khi cùng thăm dự lệ khi điểm tảm nằm trên tháng phas yên,
với từ các là khác mới dành dự.
Tổng thống gáp là mẹ put in và nhà lĩnh đạo châu tiên,
kiểm trao uống đã tiên hàng của gặp sông phương,
tại nhà khác đi ông ngưu đài ở tụi đối bất kinh của Trung Quốc.
Cuộc gặp của ý nghĩa quan trong thách chặt mối quan hệ giữa gặp bà châu tiên,
theo hẳng tiên Ria, Nó BOSS T,
tổng thống thống put in đã khẳng định với nhà lĩnh đạo kiên rằng
mối quan hệ tiên các yvr hữu gây dựng nà và châu tiên đang phát triển theo một cách thức đặc biệt.
Tổng thống put in đã bây giờ to cảm ơn về sự ủng hộ của châu tiên đối với nhà lĩnh đạo biệt,
là việc cử bị sĩ tham gia phòng thu tình gös, trước lửa lựa uống của anh nà,
về phần mình như lấy đạo kiểm trao uống châu biệt,
mối quan hệ dựa hành nước đang phát triển trên tất cả các lĩnh vực.
Đông thời khẳng định sẽ tiếp tục cùng của con này xong phương với nhà lĩnh đạo nài lĩnh Ui Thêm,
chỗ tiên sẽ chắc chẳng hú chậu ngà trong bất kỳ lĩnh vực nào trong phát vi khả năng của mình.
Tế thu khỏe đam, tổng hunga phù tiên ông hôn thần tình góa mời ổn kiêm thăm mắt cửa,
không khi tiếp sức giữa hàng nhận đạo cho thời quan hệ ngà châu,
đang tiếp tục con mước tiên mời sau khi hạt bên khi hệ hữu lựa tắc trên lựa toàn diện vào năm ngoái.